on this episode we will call and show
again because that's the only way we do
the show now
[Music]
[Music]
this is
Carrie be
[Music]
what is the interest very light yeah
tell me I'm sure I'm not joking
everybody visit up to 240 enjoy gödel L
am right here today nearly shot and this
or 241 okay thank you
hello my name is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this month of 241 of the ask Gary B show
we've been calling in it's been going
well expensive it's a nice day there's a
lot going on there's also periscope
Facebook Instagram we are bringing it
live hardcore and all of you guys been
paying attention to the YouTube numbers
I'm sure all of you have because they
asked every call-in shows tails people
are excited for this show it's quality
it's good and I love the call in
nature's allowing you to go deep so
right now the way we've been taking
numbers if you don't follow me on
Instagram
you're making a huge mistake because
that's where we get the numbers from
that's what Chris is doing his thing you
ready all right hit it
here we go first caller excited hello
what's me oh no Commission Sebastian
this is Gary Vee and you're on the
askgaryvee show
yeah baby what's up Gary
life is good where you from I'm from
Jersey City man I love it the jersey
love what can I help you with oh man so
I have this company called sexy nurse
singer we we are the premier night life
event freaking earth and oh man my
heart's racing now Dora Dora is that it
was getting towed because thank you huge
opportunity for uh for Andy keg he's
engineered a lot hi Sally
she's not in here sexy one that's right
Andy yeah actually that actually got a
whole crew that you know is out there
yourself being the leader I already know
sure so what are you I was happening to
again so we're in another space of
enjoying successful parties arrested 15
months in New York City um without this
fantas curanto I want to get into the
eSports field um we have huge plays or
nostalgia our parties and ninety scenes
you bring out 964 is crazy
video games cosplay it's like a mini
comic-con I guess my question fuse I'm
reaching a point where I'm
cunningness on my own as an individual
and actually completing this like
feeling where I feel like I need like
money to expand but at the same time I
don't want to take money silly I kind of
want to own my money
me 100% my intuition is that if you
found a failed driven media person and
made them your business Carter who's 10
years your senior and gave them 10 to 20
percent of the company
you could explode somebody who's got a
rolodex that can get a brand that wants
to tap into this audience like like if
your parties are going off like that and
you've got the momentum at your creative
director and entrepreneur there's you
know there's in your brand's there's
there's all sorts of brands you know
frito-lay there's all sorts of brands
but you could probably rack up a nice
little kind of six-figure revenue
business just based on the rolodex of
some guy or girl that works at Tommy
calm or Starcom or ever will be so my
intro like this feels like the exact
example of not about money but about
part of it everybody right now isn't
about money right everybody's about
raising capital smart money first I'm
the smartest [ __ ] money you can get
but I'm not going to help because I'm
busy so my hundred thousand is remark
but I'll talk to you like four times I'd
rather you get smart partner instead of
smart money so I would go out and get a
sales man or woman who works in the
media space who's all right the way you
interview them is you go into like
meetup comm you hit up all people on
LinkedIn who got who work at mine share
and media best at these media buying
agencies who have Rolla dentist who have
rolodexes to agencies and brands and who
from day one are into this concept and
you can do the very nice event marketing
business predicated and easily this is a
seven-figure business if your parties
get big enough and you can have a
sponsor brandman is a real saying
nightlights activations of n marketing's
real business but people that the people
that make the most money or the ones
that fell ahead of where they're at and
that's not fake if you make it that's
hey give me money to be a sponsor and
I'll give you two year deal and if you
believe in me and I deliver you're going
to feel the sponsorship from me because
over the next two years they'll be way
more you
I'm going I see exactly your you're the
marketer and the creative director you
need somebody who can subsidize the
sales funnel and the biz dev that's the
partner you need let's go an excellent
and myself being oh I'm in the sales
background well look funny well then
maybe we the other person
right right I do hate that somebody who
is my senior like 10 years down the line
but I feel like I know what I'm
explaining I just kind of am like in the
forest and that I can't get a force from
the tree experience the biggest mistake
kids are making right now is a lack
experience and so what they're doing is
they think these fees are going to give
them a few fees and Angel that sort of
they give you money then all time what
you need is actual grinding partner the
biggest mistake kids are making right
now they're not everybody thinks that
they can just do it like and by the way
maybe you can but if you're calling in
you're looking for advice and it feels
like to me that's that senior partner
there's so many 33 year olds that hate
their job made a couple bucks that are
looking for that business find them
wow that's great hey Jerry while I'm
looking for these people and the idea in
terms of the eSports players versus what
equity I could build and everything that
we're talking about because I'm looking
for the money I'm looking for the
partner but I'm also looking to bring as
much to the table myself so that I have
to keep as much in but in the long run
what do you mean by sweaty what do you
mean by that
like who is a covering up what yeah I'm
actually looking to assemble an eSports
team and using that social Manuel yeah
now you're talking about a totally
different thing now you're talking about
like you just set them you have got a
doughnut shop but I'm also going to
start a junkyard business they have
nothing but other I guess if there's
some retro [ __ ] but you're making a
convenient fit in because you believe in
the eSports sense you're getting into a
whole different business you know can
you can you drink out of two hoses in a
world where one hose is over filling
your mouth that's the thing I would
debate their class inaccessible thank
you so my god resin every opportunity
buy you lunch on res BFO thank you deep
them look thank you you too brother
anybody yeah I mean I think the theme of
that call is very simple which is there
was two very specific themes that so
many of you are going through number one
everybody wants to raise money in a
world where
percent of the startup especially
youngsters I see need a business partner
to fill out their their operations or
financials their sales they're creative
so that's number one that was a clear
theme and number two he was trying to
force fit that he was doing retro gaming
and that's why he should be in the
eSport game that's two different things
it's hard to beat two people at the same
time who is this
Jojo can it go Jojo this is Gary
Vaynerchuk hearing on the askgaryvee
show what's going on Gary life is good
you mean while working hard you know
trying to hustle I get it
what can I help you with um so I want to
ask your advice on something let's say
you have like a business that was going
well you built it up from the ground
it's a custom clothing and apparel you
know sneakers hats all that I was
getting on celebrities and you know I
get a lot of shoutouts when I'm a lot of
tags in a lot of tracks on Instagram and
then my account got disabled why into a
[ __ ] um acceptable now it was like
acceptable use policy and I was going
back and forth with them and I still
haven't gained access to account so I
also had a personal account but it
wasn't as big as that one so you know
sales decreased dramatically and I'm
just trying to gain traction and I
wonder if you like has some advice you
know like it's basically took a
bulldozer and knocked down my whole
business and like what Outland customers
know where to go you know what I'm
saying
hell yeah oh you're saying when you I am
so scared of everybody building all
their businesses on top of these
platforms and not realizing that that
can happen now to be very frank with you
bro like it's not that easy to get
disabled there's plenty of people that
have clothing brands that are getting
shout out so I don't know if you got
really lucky or if there's something
you're not telling me or if there's
something you don't know what happened
but it's like you know it's not that
easy some something happened you know I
don't know what what I would say is this
the lesson here is you can never be
reliant on just one platform they can't
judge me about Instagram it can't just
be about YouTube they can't just be
about Twitter right you have two ways to
communicate with people outside of just
one way you need to collect cell phone
numbers you need to collect
no addresses and you could build up
profiles or all sorts of platforms you
know I don't know I don't know what
other advice that can really give you I
think what you need to do is go back
into the comments of every shoutout you
got some of them probably disappeared
some are still there hashtags I mean
truth is sometimes you just start over
yeah I know I don't know you know like
outside of like if you listen send me an
email to Gary at vaynermedia I'll see if
I can dig in to this I don't have any
big relationship with Instagram or the
next guy maybe I'll take a look but like
you know other than getting it
reinstated which is hard because it's a
big company it's not like something like
yeah cool got you like you know so I
think you got a restart and be smart
build up you know one thing I think
people need to build up is cell phone
numbers like do contests get people
reasons to give you their cell phone
number that doesn't go away so easy more
than I was doing like the whole mail
trip and everything tries to whatever
email address but you know getting come
on your hard emails yeah give them a
reason no listen I would secures what we
do I would send them an email right now
then to everybody and say look building
back up my cows go follow me here I'm
doing this giving away 50 hats but give
them incentive to get back into the
following of you okay all right all
right thank you good luck man one other
question what is the address for your
thing available online I could just send
you some gear or yes it's on banner
media put it to attention Tyler just the
Tyler Network
he's a Tyler I think she's fancy cool
Thank You Network research appreciate
you masks a well lesson they're very
simple everybody's doing it right now
you can't be reliant on just one
platform you know everybody you know
this is deja boo' 2004 all my friends
hitting me up like yo Google [ __ ] me
they didn't algorithm change I used to
be the first result for hacks now on
page 19 my business collapsed like yeah
the old brand build other funnels they
never want to be you never want to be at
the mercy of a platform you know
singular impact on your business now you
could also run short businesses and you
extract the most you can but then why
you always want to build the biggest
brand you want to build multiple things
I highly recommend all of you to build
out
the tie build-out different places to
not be at the mercy of platform email
and phone number have been hello ty yeah
this is Gary Vaynerchuk and you're on
the askgaryvee show
holy [ __ ] where you from brother
Orlando's in the house good to see you
what can I help you with well but I
didn't get that last part I what can I
help you
what can answer for you um so I'm in
high school right now and I'm like just
a hair away from dropping out and I
really don't know what to do okay give
me some more time how old are you 17
are you in your junior year yes well
your parents punch you in the face
probably and you want to drop out
because um I mean I really just want to
pursue like my business aspirations but
I don't know if I like that getting on
my case about it I don't know
I hear you so are you good at business
are you making money right now
um yeah I actually just opened a Shopify
store and I've been using Facebook as to
bring in revenue industry working out
pretty well what are you selling ah just
iPhone cases right now about I start
putting bad hats on there too so I think
the thing that you need to think about
is do you actually have a like look
dropping at a high school is pretty high
risk because the world still gives a
[ __ ] about that if you ever have to get
another job now yes if you are willing
to eat [ __ ] for the next 12 years and
live with like 13 roommates in a studio
in Orlando like to drop like you know
I'm the you know me I'm pure
entrepreneur I speak very aggressively
against schools value to real
entrepreneurs with what you got to
promise me ty is this like you got to
really figure out if you're a good
entrepreneur like this is a very
high-risk need like high school like
that's like we're now getting into like
no high school diploma you're getting
into no jobs like you've got to
basically know at a very young age
which is very hard at 17 if you're
willing to take this massive risk
because you can't get a job anywhere it
doesn't pay anything above minimum wage
if you're unable to be successful yeah
absolutely like do you like have you all
like you know what I'm scared of and
you've heard me talk about this like are
you into a cos entrepreneurship school
now or were you like not believing when
you were seven and always wanted to sell
blow pops I mean like I really first
started like I was in middle school and
everybody started smoking Smarties and
my first instinct was like I went to
Walmart bought a fatass pack of Smarties
and started selling Smarties before I
got in trouble good that's a good start
I actually like that that means your
natural intuition is to be a failed guy
here I would say you know list of nobody
needed school more than me and I was
able to eat that [ __ ] so I mean at some
level like I don't know like like why do
you want to quit like like like can't
you just mail it in I'm going to push
you through the system anyway I mean it
would be like dropping out it'd be more
like getting my GED you know but why not
just like go have fun for six hours a
day like Network and like do like
consumer insights and just like like do
what I do I literally did nothing I
didn't pay attention in class I never
did homework and I got apps on all my
tests they're still going to push you
through the system true true and then
then you just go and just like you're
never to be 17 again and then we're
going to live in the life you never to
live in a light you drop out now you got
stress you have no [ __ ] stress now
you might think this Wisconsin is a pain
in the ass that ain't [ __ ] compared to
real life yeah hey hey and socially like
it's getting more fun if you're in
school like what kind of grades are
getting these an aspirin kind of like
kind of like still oh no I'm doing well
doesn't it here's what I would say you
fake dropping out get these an F okay
and like use your time thinking about
your business like I used to be the Wine
Spectator in class like I was just roll
into science class and just why not look
at your phone when they're not looking
or just they dream about strategies I
think there's just a way to apply I
think there's a way for you to have your
cake and eat it too where your dad
doesn't whip
more and my ass at the same time yeah I
hear that so like like if you really
want to drop out of school the first
move is to just get really bad grades
and get through yeah I think you're just
going to the extreme yeah for sure
I needed this I appreciate it my
pleasure man keep me updated okay yeah
of course I mean I take care value too
and by the way flipping like iPhone
cases and like Alec it's not a good
business like you'll get caught the
algorithm will change your commoditized
you're you're doing sales you're not
building a business way too many people
getting confused so understand what that
means and get back to me and then we can
have this discussion again okay yeah man
take care bye bye
I mean if you told me I was going to
keep kids in school I would figure real
money getting getting uh getting soft in
my older age that was fun that was just
insane yeah I mean I think look I think
what tide is a young man but I think
it's a great way for me to segue
obviously I think finding my Caden -
you're giving advice on top of ice while
we do the phone call thing you don't
have to go zero to 100 so I created now
I can point to it and crush it I wrote
about 7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the morning
because you don't want to quit your job
to follow your dream you can just quit
your your bullshitting and you can quit
your watching TV and quit your knees er
to build your dream and so I'm quite
practical from what all my infinity and
that's the advice I gave time right now
you don't go from being doing pretty
well in high school dropping out of high
school just mail it in school mockery
she fell to the kids from high school
Nick come on okay
who's this Oh Gary this is Gary what's
your name hello hello this is Gary
what's your name
oh I'm trembling I can't believe this
you made it Wow okay my name is Scioscia
my name is Kim Anna I've been I'm a
helper I'm a fan of your since like I
found you I found a seashell shot um I
had a friend where you trying to get
all right we're comin down feels like it
where are you from how old are you honey
I'm sorry
my 24 I'm originally from Venezuela and
I'm currently living in Boston okay also
boy are you a Patriots fan
no I'm not a patriot advance good I like
that they were able to unite let's not
go any further let me go all right so
okay yeah I know I have no words what
can I help you building my second
business trying to connect teachers from
Ben as well and the u.s. just trying to
help out in the professional development
so let's say that you were a student to
air that we're restricting what classes
or what techniques would you tell
teachers to really use for students
conferring many of them are very
entrepreneurial so one more time help me
understand what business you're trying
to do is trying to sell consulting or
something about nature no no no no I'm
trying to do a non-profit in the EdTech
free EdTech okay perfect and so you've
got a two sided marketplace or who who
is the clock call it the who would
exclude the customer you're trying to
reach the teacher because the client the
client would end up being the tether not
necessarily a teacher
it wouldn't primarily go through the
school and it would serve as a
professional development course that
would take either situation right here I
see and I'm sold under sell in are you
selling to the district or the
superintendent like who in selling your
ad tech now so I'm selling to the
private schools amenaza the public
dominus are so deteriorated that would
it I wouldn't even make a gun so here's
my problem
the biggest reason I'm successful is
because I day trade attention and
understand market
the truth is I'm so not versed in the
current state of private schools in
Venezuela that I can't reverse engineer
Division II now yeah so no so so that
what the question was would be it is
Khalil is more adequately in curriculum
so yeah what would you do to have to for
teachers really there are no more
instrument built quicker I think the
problem for me sure you ask you about
curriculum that is taught to the kids
the problem we are I don't know the
current state of the Venezuela market
because I know enough about the human
ego Chavez regime there to me it's tough
to teach entrepreneurship so I would
never want to teach entrepreneurship in
places that weren't complete
capitalistic environments because I
don't because I'm because I come from a
communist country and I'm scared to give
advice curriculum wise that wouldn't
bode well for the kids because they have
to navigate through uncharted waters or
a new regime like so I'm going to ask
you because you're from there like
what's the state of the union of
entrepreneurial opportunities for people
within that environment that are kicked
backing and paying the government that
would shut them down if they got any
leverage actually there are actually
surprisingly enough there are a ton of
anjuman niccola that aren't necessarily
just doing it for the need of getting
students up a lot of them have to deal
with the social impact space may sound
like there's a black tub in Caracas
which is make I made a huge dent in it
there what I want to do is be able to
connect sorry no listening I'm listening
I'm trying to think on the spot because
it's not now great it's cool I have let
me ask you a question one of the things
that has caught my attention is how
underpriced the attention on social
networks in Venezuela is I would tell
you that first one of the things I would
give a lot of thought they didn't feel
comfortable building your brand and
putting out content to that market yeah
because I think I could neighbor to find
investors that are always be able to
really help out so I'm a glad to do that
right now I'm the only reason I'm really
that what you need to be able to leave
the country simple because of how
deteriorate it was but I know there's
such a huge level of people works behind
orient built the country the best piece
of advice I can give you is creating
original content to the theory of this
and in specifics and running ads against
individuals is in the marketplace
because it's an under priced attention
graph on Facebook ads okay thank you so
much I want to say or yes someone
nothing I hopeful so much and so and I'm
so inclined to be able to make honey
companies essentially banned from we
work for simply being a nice person and
knocking on people's doors no it was
just by saying so
happy that you actually answer my call I
am probably thank you so much you're
welcome have a great day you should kind
of love the series binky last one I
didn't keep in general of that call for
me is stay in your lane as much as I
wanted to give her advice I think that
you got to know where your limits and
and I think knowing the market is
imperative I think when I look at the
market it's even right now we're doing a
lot of transcription like I'm enjoying
so much reading the comments I'm hitting
the Facebook translate I'm leading the
feedback of all these different
countries because every market has its
own nuances
I've got America mapped intuitively it's
in me I'm in it and I can role and I
think other markets like the UK market
well you know Western Europe I feel
comfortable but start getting into a
post dictator socialism regime like that
as well I just don't know the nuances
and so need to be careful when you're
giving advice to stay within your lane
basically stating that a lot of you need
to pay attention to last one so here
this is Stacey Stacey this is Gary
hey Gary what's going on life is good
face how about you everything's good I
appreciate you in so many different
levels I think you have the blueprint on
so many different things that's why I
had to talk to you
well thank you where you from I'm from
Vegas I'm in the Las Vegas right now I
love it
what can I help you with a couple
questions I have been hustling in all
different realms from being with texts
to pardon me no I start up text yep
ecommerce ex-college ask me all of that
and I know it's preparing me to kind of
have success in the way I'm going so I
started my marketing company help small
businesses in regards to their social
media presence and really try to help
them to the next level okay but then I'm
hearing you every single day like people
need to fall in love with you people
need to fall in love with the brand so
I'm gonna do exactly that from my
business tips my success my failures
I've had success when I was young and I
didn't have the models assistants to
place to kind of maintain that yep so
this
time around a condom want to share my
journey with people under studies
suggest I do something else how would
you try to plug that in to kind of like
help me along my journey meaning how do
you in a weed your journey correct so
what what platform are you communicating
on have a human of Instagram and I'm
going to be starting my youtube channel
right so that part where you said I'm
going to be starting my that's the part
we need to hear us you don't need to be
rock your do rock of your phone you need
to start creating yes sir that's it it's
that crazy space it's so crazy right
like the answer is of course you've been
hearing me you don't need me the
blueprint I have is free you know it
already this is you just got to do it so
the answer is yes do I think and by the
way there's even Instagram if you just
an Instagram you can use your Instagram
account to do your content and your
marketing and you can use your insurance
stories to be your vlog it's incredible
with so many tools or some goddamn lucky
things I know no you and I are doing a
Drivetime radio show right now that
would have cost millions of dollars to
distribute just 20 years ago I'm holding
up some real [ __ ] phone and like other
Tyler's got a camera for me slide
screens going on like we're living in
unprecedented times you just have to do
I appreciate that thank you so much very
few green I'm trying to need your
reaction no no I said I appreciate you
so no I heard that yeah I've read every
book I see every livestream on yes it's
in the process like like that that
ordered but you know what I mean like I
little Jack [ __ ] [ __ ] a fit a [ __ ]
camera
[ __ ] lighting like you've got a phone ok
face what I'm scared under the covers
but everybody's reading my books and
watching everything and reading on
everybody's motivated everybody's
ordering the equipment it's what you
know what we scared that all my
followers are you know see that guy who
like 5 Roger Federer sneakers and
wristbands
and he's got an $800 racket and he's got
the headband and the water bottle and
drinks the $8 [ __ ]
electrolytes coconut water and he
stretches for 15 minutes and then he
goes on the court and you six love [ __ ]
that's what I'm scared of what winners
do which is put in the practice I want
you to take the tennis ball and hit it
against the wall because that's all
you've got a shitty racket and your wall
and you just keep hitting it over and
over and over again if they're
absolutely I still don't believe you
I don't believe that if you're going to
hang up you're going to get I'm going to
get on my throne or beneath my iPhone
what's your what's your own account
rights right
what is your Instagram account st AC te
ma stays pinyin great I'm going to keep
an eye on you absolutely
don't let them on it I promise do not
let the vaynernation down because they
will go on your they will troll the [ __ ]
out of you in a week I'm there I got you
I promise
good luck thank you you're welcome
question of the day how many of you are
that [ __ ] tennis player you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
[Music]